some of us wake up one day and we say i
want to go into real estate some wake up
they say
i want to be a cop i want to be a
bodybuilder i want to be a financial
advisor i want to be a nurse i want to
be a doctor
who wakes up and says you know what
i want to be the highest-paid drug pilot
in history how does that happen it
doesn't happen like that at all so it's
not like when you were a kid you said
when i grew up i wanted to okay i wanted
to be a farmer i wanted to you know have
a big plantation of tobacco and yeah and
then i uh i started flying and i wanted
to be a missionary aviation fellowship
pilot i wanted to fly the missionaries
in and out of the gym seriously yes
seriously that's why i learned to fly
wow and then your heart was always in
the right place
absolutely i mean i'm not
preacher but i could fly those sick
people in now the jungle and the
missionaries and bring them their mail
and there was a a nature saint started
it and with a little plane and he'd put
a rope down and put the bucket and right
at the missionaries feet and they'd put
their note in it and he'd put him some
penicillin in it and then mail and bring
it back out and they started that until
they could cut out strips in the jungle
and i thought wow what kind of wonderful
flying that would be
and then later on in the first story in
my book i tell when i was shot down over
the amazon and i was 11 days
and who rescued me except missionary
aviation fellowship
full circle apology did you did you like
uh
somehow meet a pastor that was smoking
too much weed and snorting too much coke
and you got connected is that kind of
how this happened not at all i just read
the book
and i thought i like to do that yeah
jungle pilots the name of the book the
wonderful book and they made the movie
the point of the spear
point of the spear uh-huh interesting he
was killed in in ecuador when he landed
was on a sand bar with
the indian people wow i'm assuming
you've been to ecuador as well yes yes
beautiful place
so so you're going you're doing what
you're doing and then you become a pilot
and then somehow somewhere you get
affiliated with these folks
it happens so gently let me just tell
you how how close suddenly these things
can come about
i was a i had a farm in georgia
and
i put in 36 000 lay in chickens and
purina
promoted it and the price of feed went
up and the price of eggs went down until
every time i picked up a dozen eggs i
was making
i was losing five cents and i was losing
the farm
so i
started turning that chicken feed into
moonshine whiskey and i made a thousand
gallons a week
and you can read over i got all
they emptied their bullets at me trying
to kill me and blew my steel up and i
lost it lost everything so when i quit
running i was in california
so i went to work into construction
worked with that a couple of years and
then i got on the redondo beach fire
department
and so i was only five years
and uh oh it was a good job it took
it was hard to get on it's like winning
the lottery to get on it
but uh
i i had a little painting crew and i
have bringing antiques from missouri
back selling them and i was making quite
a bit of money
and one day i was reading a national
geographic magazine as i bumped across
country with the other guy and it said
mercury in mexico was a dollar and it
was 13 in the united states and i said
i should bring some of that back when i
go down in my little airplane he said oh
man
you want to bring some of that marijuana
back i said i don't know nothing about
it i heard about the kid smoking it he
said it's the hottest thing you've seen
what year is it sorry 1973. okay
so all the cool kids are smoking that
marijuana we're just starting yeah so i
said well tell me about it and so he
introduced me to a fellow said you got
an airplane yeah and he said would you
be interested what do you pay
so he says let me introduce you to
somebody so he called somebody and a
fellow came over and said i'll give you
ten thousand dollars and i said well
throw some of that hay in there
hey that's the nickname that's well yeah
well i mean it looked like a little bit
of hay to me in the back seat of my
airplane it was no big deal and i come
home and landed and give them their
stuff and they give me ten thousand
dollars in a bag and i brought it home
and shook it on the bed and the baby
got a hundred dollar bills and crawling
around and my wife put her hand over her
mouth and i said let's go out to dinner
you know let's celebrate
so then i said wow now that i don't know
about that that wasn't nothing
so i went to a lawyer and i put a
hundred dollars to building his desk and
i said mr lawyer
what would happen to me if i got caught
bringing some marijuana across the
border in my plane
he said what's your criminal history
i said i've never had a speeding ticket
not even a parking ticket he said you
work on the fire department yes sir i
work
he said man you'll get probation
at the very worst
you would get one year and spend four
months raking leaves
so i thought that's the business for me
so i bought a cessna 207 that would
carry 1100 pounds and i'm making 40
thousand dollars when i want to go down
so i brought my mother out from
georgia to disneyland and picked her up
my new cadillac and took her to
disneyland she said what you doing boy i
said
i'm hauling pot mo
you told her yeah and she said how much
you making i said i'm making 40 000 any
day i want to go down there
he said what did they do if he catch you
and i told her what the lawyer said and
i said what do you think mom
she said do you need a co-pilot
that makes all the sense in the world
that's that's family values
my mom's like
absolutely were you giving your mom
money at this point uh yes i took care
of my mother i was gonna know my family
yes
how different would it been if mom said
don't do it how different would it been
if she said you shouldn't do it it
wouldn't matter it would have made a
difference got it she would have said it
or not you would have done it anymore oh
yeah why do you ask that because
the parenting obviously i'm just curious
i'm here to know if he was asking for
confirmation or if he was asking for
like i remember i was working at bally's
in chatsworth and
chatsworth at the time was 80 to porn
and the guy comes in with a pretty girl
and they're sitting there saying how
much money do these guys pay you per
month i say they pay me you know three
four grand a month he says how would you
like to make that every weekend i had no
idea what he was talking about
then he says uh uh he says well you know
you look like you'd make a hell of an
actor
i said really you've never seen me act
he says you just got the personality for
it i said great
they figured me out in hollywood he said
yeah direction this is going so uh he
says uh you know you ever done adult
films i said like like movies for adult
people like you know like ready raw he
says no like adult adult so what are you
talking about he says pointless and i'm
not gonna do porn he said if you ever
wanted to would pay you four grand a
movie so after you did your first movie
what happened well i got paid four grand
no no but but i went home and i told my
dad i said dad so let me tell you what
happened to me today and i told my dad
my dad's like if you ever do it yeah you
can never call me your dad again really
i said dad what are you going to say if
your friends see this thing that's
gabriel's son think about it if your
older friend cedar is they're going to
say that's gabriel's son and wouldn't
you be proud of that he says no i don't
want you to touch himself no that's
dirty obviously it says you sought his
counsel no i didn't i was teasing oh
gosh of course i was giving him a hard
time but
that's the story i was curious enough
there was a conversation with mom to see
what mom would say so okay so he says so
she says 40 000 do you need a co-pilot
that's right at any time you can go and
make 40k and come back right
so what do you do then you just keep
doing them keep doing them
i want to make 300 000 and go back to
farm and i got 300 000 right quick yeah
my wife says you must not remember like
i do all that heat and bugs and
rattlesnakes hoeing and digging
she didn't want to go back so we stayed
instead what stayed in california in
redondo beach yes sir you didn't want to
go back to uh to georgia no you don't
want to do that okay your goal was three
hundred thousand as well
and you got the goal bam and you said
and how long did it take to get that a
couple weeks months we could i break
into three months probably two or three
months so in three months you reached
your goal yes and you just
the the taste of all that money was too
sweet to turn up you know turn up it was
just nothing it was just like there was
nothing between united states and mexico
but a barbed wire fence i mean and you
couldn't even find that just right i
flew across real low and it didn't
matter so just coming just one run after
the other so was there a goal to say
babe once we make this much money i'll
stop or was it just a full-on
addiction to saying next one next one
next one let's get some more because i
know you said 300 000 and i would stop
yeah well i would have i mean my father
went to the farm but then you're there
and you're sitting there with an
airplane i'm still working on the fire
department i got every four days off i'd
go down there and do it and come back
and it was just nothing it was
absolutely just i'd go down and go
fishing
and and and your fire department guys
are not asking you they're like how do
you actually get that cattle like oh
yeah they reported me or they did report
you so that's how it happened certainly
well that didn't that didn't matter
on on
uh load 13
i had that little feeling in my stomach
like ding ding ding this guy walking we
had to land at a i landed in a little
900 foot strip if you could call it that
on the bend of a river in the sand and
there was water coming through a little
waterfall and a river about knee deep
and i'd go then brush my teeth and take
take fuel they had fuel and fill me up
and then the young fella named robert
anyhow a young fellow would get in the
airplane with me
pedro
and uh
we would go over where he would tell me
to go on a highway maybe 20 30 miles
away and they had two trucks and machine
guns on it and i'd land between those
trucks and they had like a bucket
brigade they'd put the marijuana in the
airplane and i'd shake hands with all of
them and take off and they'd be 20 or 30
cars parked
waiting a highway patrolman in there
with no no lights on and i'd take over
that and go home and unload it
but on day 13 on the morning
we got in the plane in pow
i thought a tire blew out and i looked
and he said please see up roger please
see a please see ya and it dawned on me
but we only had 400 feet from the end of
the runway
and because i'd park down about halfway
and just at daylight i just brushed my
teeth into the river and these men
around there and i just put it was a
cessna 207 a big big stretch cessna
and when i got to the end of the runway
i just pulled it up
and when i did there was four of them
that just
riddled that airplane with four ak-47
they put 80 bullet holes in it she hit
me across the top of my head knocked my
kneecap off in the end of my toe
and then shot his foot nearly off
and so i thought i mean
the windshield was all out and they'd
hit the tank up on the other side and
the gasoline was just gushing in on me
and they hit the strut right by my head
and the spattered is all in my face
hundreds of pieces of lead just
spattered all over me and i thought i
was gonna die i really did i thought i
was gonna burst into flames with all
that gasoline and i just pulled the
power and it went
went to hit that river and it looked
like
huge
turtles the way the rocks were formed i
remember [ __ ] and when i hit the wings
came off and the next time the nose came
under the plane
and and stopped in the water
and i was knocked out he was shaking me
roger come on roger come on so we jumped
out and they were still shooting the
plane and come up hit well on top of the
um
on top of the radio i had taped in a
holster a nine millimeter
you were ready
no i just had that in case i crashed
somewhere you would like to have
something in the jungle if you i didn't
i didn't have it for people or nothing
just had something
kind of i don't know just like a little
survival kit self-defense yeah so anyway
i took that pistol and they was running
down the runway toward me and i shot a
few shots popped a few caps and they ran
into in the stones in the they were big
boulders everywhere and we started
running and i saw that pedro's foot was
nearly shot off
i mean it was just a shot through the
through and i took my t-shirt off and it
wasn't even bleeding but it was just
torn out i guess the stress and we went
up the hill through the cactus and there
was an old donkey
charlotte charlotte
and he caught that donkey and we got on
and rode and roads we came to a little
house and and there was some people they
went for help we sit there all day long
and uh that's that's a heck of a story i
can finish it if you want me to then
what happened how did you get out of it
that day all right so i finished it then
so there was a little house and i see a
usual in a man plowing with a a cow and
a an aux
a cow and a little mew
with a the harness over him and he was
plowing and so pedro talked to him and
they put us in the house and the woman
put
uh cloth and put diesel fuel all over us
to keep the flies and the bugs off and
we sat there all day long
and about dark about 20 horses and mules
come into that yard
and there was a doctor there dr benjamin
so so and he got in there and he i was
slugging my foot and he was trying to
find it
and he'd give us morphine and shot us up
and give us tetanus shot and whatever
he said you got to get out of here they
got roadblocks everywhere looking and
they think the americans in here and
dead because of all the blood that was
in the plane
so
they put us on mules and horses and we
rode to a road then we come to a dirt
road and there was a big truck there's a
tin wheeler and it was loaded with corn
in the ear
and they dug holes in that corn and all
those mexican guys got on there with the
big hats and serapis and i guess it was
kind of cold and we put us under the
corn and that truck would just
and the corn would fall over and they
kept pushing my face out
and we came finally to the highway and
they they uh they got us out oh we got
stopped three times by did you pay these
guys off no no they were just why would
it help you they just just wanted to be
helpful oh yes they just did they knew
who you were though did they have it
they had to do they beca but anyhow
they're wonderful people down in mexico
they're wonderful yes but they they knew
you were on the run oh yes people on the
inside they knew all they knew you were
on the inside with who there's a mexican
cartel at this point no no there was no
such thing as that it was just country
folks just farmers and it was growing
pot and but these were just people just
helping us and that dr benjamin so-so
but
they get got a taxi for me to go to
guadalajara because they said they got
all the roads blocked north
so they got a dwarf guy to become and he
had a new car
and he talked and they propped me up
with
the pills and uh
bandaged up and got some clothes for me
and i i remember that night we talked
all night long and again i said do you
have any children oh see senor i have a
beautiful wife and three boys
let me tell you how i got my beautiful
wife dora
he said you see me no girl would look at
me
but there was a girl in the village that
i had my eye on and she was playing in a
band she was playing the flute at the
back and i grabbed her and pulled her
into the yard and my mother helped us
get in the house
and i told her i love her and we sit
there all night but she wouldn't look at
us and the next morning senior we had to
let her go so she went to her father and
she knocked on the door and he said get
away from here you prostitute you've
been away all night with some man you're
not a daughter of mine and she walked
away with her head down and i said dora
let's go talk to the priest
and send you with that's how i got it
wow well i'm not through let me just you
just just just a little bit more
and he said and then one year later we
had a beautiful baby boy and i had a
ford
and we named him ford
and the next year senor you won't
believe it but we had a beautiful baby
another boy and i had a dodge and we
named him dog
and i know senor you won't believe this
but three years
though three years later
we had another young boy and i was
driving a new chevrolet and that damn
priest wouldn't name him chevrolet had
to teach him to drive to get him to name
him chevrolet and that's how i got my
three boys ford dodge and chevrolet
unbelievable can you imagine any of your
kids after three cars it's kind of like
four brothers dallas denver
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]